fue electo hoy como el líder de El
senado será el portavoz de La minoría en
el senado recordemos que los demócratas
en estas elecciones de medio mandato
ganaron sostuvieron la mayoría en el
senado misma Connor Pues ahora
representa una fracción del partido
republicano que se opone a el ex
presidente Donald Trump y de hecho hoy
en rueda de prensa mismo no certificó no
quiso dar el apoyo a la candidatura de
El ex presidente Donald Trump para la
presidencia en el 2024 le ganó a Rick a
Rick Perry que quería ser el líder
republicano en el senado Repair pues era
Pues un Aliado de Donald Trump era fue
gobernador de la Florida ahora es
senador por la Florida y es bastante
curioso que se divida así el el partido
republicano porque muestra además Pues
esta nueva fracción que hay en el
partido del ex presidente Donald Trump
maestro además que pues hay una fracción
bastante grande que precisamente no está
de acuerdo con la radicalización del
partido y lo demostró en esta votación
al elegir a Miss mccona como líder de su
partido en la cámara de representantes
que era entonces Kevin mccarthy que al
confirmarse ya prontamente el voto
número 218 en esta elección de medio
mandato pasaría a ser Entonces el
presidente de la cámara de
representantes otro tema Cristóbal que
concentra la atención en Estados Unidos
es la votación del senado para que el
matrimonio igualitario se convierta en
una ley federal
sí llama la atención y está en proceso
de votarse es 62 senadores votaron a
favor de que este proyecto de proteger
el matrimonio igualitario y el
matrimonio interracial pase a debate
finales ese debate final se podría dar
finalizando esta semana y esto ocurre
teniendo en cuenta que los demócratas
pues todavía tienen la mayoría no
solamente en el senado sino en la cámara
de representantes antes de que empiece
el próximo año y quieren aprovechar esta
mayoría precisamente para pasar leyes de
este corte que estaban pendientes en
esta legislatura además quieren
aprovechar también este cuarto dior esta
mayoría que tienen después de que la
Corte Suprema de Justicia pues haya
prohibido el derecho como un el aborto
como un derecho federal y entonces pues
quieren aprovechar para proteger el
matrimonio interracial y el matrimonio
igualitario después de que varios
republicanos hayan dicho que querían
acabar con este al respecto el
presidente se pronunció y dijo que
cualquier estadounidense tiene que tener
y debe tener el derecho a casarse con la
persona que ama y le dijo al congreso
que le pasen esta ley cuanto antes a su
escritorio y que él la firmaría apenas
llegues a ley a su a su escritorio a su
oficina para proteger el matrimonio
igualitario en Estados Unidos